hot rod what's up homie there he is i'm
at my home studio and i appreciate you
guys spitting isaiah 55 8 right that's
55 8 right
[Music]
not your thoughts nor your ways my way
says the lord okay listen
mike smith let me tell you this brother
i was thinking the same thing i was
saying you know what it's sometimes when
you go through something and we've all
gone through a lot of different things
sometimes it's not about you and
sometimes people don't realize your
worth until you're not there you know
what i mean so everybody's taken back
for for granted but now that he's gone
they're gonna really see what type of
leader he is what type of player he is
what he brought every single day his
work ethic his level of focus just the
leadership this is a kid that never
complained about anything he never
complained about anything all he did was
come to work and when you saw those
tears of him going away it wasn't about
a hundred million dollar contract it was
the fact that he could not be on there
with beat and play games the rest of
this year with his teammates that's what
it was truly about mike
and
takes that support sorry michael i just
said i hope he takes the support that
he's getting and and really uh
appreciates it and embraces it and and
and is fueled by it because this is a
young man we talk about the physical
recovery mentally we know he's been
through a lot emotionally he's been
through a lot this year
uh with his family was speaking out
about it in terms of you know his mental
health struggles so i just hope he's
uplifted by all that outpouring you're
talking about right go ahead michael i'm
sorry
no no i'm just gonna ask rodney um
and we look at it here
all of the all of the support for
dak prescott i know you've been in that
situation before
where
you get an injury in san diego still san
diego at the time brings you to new
england
and then i remember in new england you
got an injury and you're you're being
carried off the field and you're waving
and i was like man like that's like the
end of his career but what is it tell me
what what that fraternity is like what's
happening in that moment
like why do we see that with players you
see him going at it during the game but
when somebody gets hurt you see a
different side of the nfl community tell
us about that well that's the thing that
you can't control everybody knows that
when you play any type of sports you
can't control you know you just can't
control injuries and you see a guy and
his foot is over that way and the first
thing you're thinking about is not just
his career but you're thinking about his
family you're thinking about him and how
he's going to deal with it yeah
obviously it's going to be a big factor
him not being on the field but you just
empathize with that guy because that's
something that as long as you play
football you never ever want to have to
go through an injury like that now
people are second-guessing and saying is
his career on the line so yeah you're
very empathetic to a guy seeing him
especially a good guy dak is a good
person he is a he is an example that i
would love for both of my sons both 16
and 13 years old to follow a guy like
kim
yeah word um you know i don't i don't
buy my kids um my son in particular
i don't buy many jerseys mainly because
they get outdated pretty quickly you
know to me with players moving from team
to team but also to your point like that
is a jersey that he had when he was
little because of just how he conducts
himself uh just he was already rodney my
man of the year for 2020 because of the
stance and and the voice that he gave to
mental health struggles we just showed a
bunch of the tweets people shouting out
alex smith one of the greatest comebacks
we've seen from a catastrophic
catastrophic injury in recent memory
maybe dak is now in line
uh for comeback player uh of the year
next year uh given what we know he can
do once he gets back in healthy so um
hey guys think about this
i'm sorry i'm sorry think about this too
and i i said this yesterday when i was
um on nbc
you think about
with dak being injured there's gonna be
four or five teams that are still really
really interested in that and willing to
give him an opportunity i mean you look
at the jets the jaguars the bears the um
the washington even if possibly the
falcons i mean dak is still a young man
he works extremely hard he takes care of
his body you talked about the mental
aspect of it um he's a smart smart young
man there's gonna be four or five teams
that would love to have him as their
leader and and four or five owners that
would love for them for him to represent
their organization as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports